well a first year PhD student buys a
Yasha windchill today I'm going to talk
about d3 quotes and the interplay
between these three words which I've
been doing or thinking for past month
and this is the work done with all these
amazing details so thanks to them okay
just to give the overview of my talk my
talk would be focused mostly on like
transfer learning multitask learning and
better learning sort of problem my
experimental confident reinforcement
learning settings but I'll used or try
to use the terminology so that everyone
who is not even familiar with
reinforcement learning would actually be
able to understand it and the fourth
section of the talk is going to talk
about something I call parametric
generalization which I say a new way of
evaluating generalization in transfer
learning multitask learning or meta
learning cause then I'm going to talk
about the methods through which you can
learn vector by field which helps you
transfer or generates better and then
going to talk about some ongoing work
which kind of provides a unified theory
for of these three first works
certain so the biggest challenge right
now in reinforcement learning are more
specifically artificial intelligence is
to devise methods which engine light the
opinion beliefs seem impressive result
on one problems or single problems even
surpassing human deterrence but the key
lies in how and we train an agent okay
how can we train a model to solve many
problems at the same time so in the
sense that we are able to train
specialists that as models which
contains one single problem with how to
paint generalist status which can
actually solve more multiple problems at
the same point so in order to solve this
problem
wondering why not even think start
thinking about this problem they can't
say issue how do you actually know that
agent is actually using its past
experiences or how do you actually know
that it ended actually enhancing its
knowledge over the course of like online
learning or the course of continued
learning because there could be many
issues going on but as if you keep on
training the agent on new and new tasks
it has positive the knowledge about
parses or it treats a particular task in
the future which it has not seen and it
has to learn it so how do you know that
actually agent is actually learning and
start just am writing so that it can
generate the knowledge and be able to
generate for the new toss so know should
be within these kind of settings the
researcher or the structuring already
calyxes to the factors of variation so
what I'm talking about so this is a
picture from a recently tested from
allah called a bi a platform for b bi in
which the agent is trained to Train many
problems like the alien has to navigate
to a particular goal they didn't have to
use a key to reach the goal they didn't
have to sidestep an object and the key
bridges spinet the object and then go
the goals and stuff like that the faces
are series of tasks and role of the
agent or the goal of the researcher
its final learning algorithm which can
actually solve all these nothing to
solve
problems if I am learning about them it
could actually make it easier for new
problems which station doesn't know yet
to make it easier for learn those
problems then the sense on the problems
that you are dealing with the touch
distribution is I was that our situation
is growing and the targets tribution is
composition is that it's composed of
your most of that by the way anyone can
stop me in between I don't really want
to go through my slides so if you think
something is not clear please feel free
to stop me or something which you think
that I'm saying is maybe not right so in
most of the problems like we actually do
simulation that we had except to the
simulator and that simulator has access
to like you have some factors of
variation which responsible for the data
generating distribution behind those
particular simulator or an experiment so
quite example in this particular
experiment given the object and the
given the relationship between these
objects and given the field of view of
the NHIN and given the structure of the
room you can actually generate a wide
distribution of tasks then the sense
these are the factors of variation which
are responsible for generating in task
or something any task so it's important
to note that literally all these
problems we had access to these factors
of variation so can we use these factors
of creation can we use this knowledge in
order to actually test how well or how
robust are learning algorithms are or
how will or our adaptive these actually
are the right self so one single way
through a later learning algorithm or
learning in eighteen is let's say you
are given the distribution of tasks you
sample particular environment and you
have like many episodes in that
particular environment and you evaluate
this particular quantity which says that
basically maximize the expected reward
so in the sense let's say you have many
tasks first shootout steals when they
crease the goal second task feels like
find the key and then reach the goal and
stuff like that
so the object becomes to maximize the
return and that's what people really use
for you auditing the agents but
completely your according to me this
objective doesn't really tell you
anything about the learning here here
it's possible that Illumina got them
done it jujin twice I can perform
variables across one party affiliation
but miniature form will across another
factor of variation and that particular
mismatch on which balance won't be
actually reflected in this particular
object there but can we do something
smarter can we do something which led to
how well or how well each interaction
generalizing so that can you forgive
yourself how which lets us know
something your specific or more
intuitive about their behavior and I
think the answer is yes so this is sort
of a variation what let's see what we
have we know that if I'm agent and if
I'm protocol environment I have exists
to the factors of variation so why not
just use those factors of variation to
actually value generalization what I
mean by that gentleman can evaluate
generalization in interpolation and
extrapolation the interpolation means
that you kind of train on the same
example as the Finney distribution an
extrapolation means between and more
specific examples which were not in your
training distribution so in order to
have a concrete example let's say you
train an agent in order to reach a
particular goal and let's say you train
like on
rooms five rooms section seven and two
rooms so during interpolation you can
actually train on films but during
extrapolation you can actually test your
AJ on ten groups so can we use the same
concept and evaluate the agents across
different patterns of variation status
yet these different parts of the
variation you have the most rooms you
have failed the agent here number of
objects you have relationship between
the objects which are in the length
factor the one way of evaluating
generalization would be actually to do
in population as well
extrapolation along a particular factor
so you would imagine a 2d matrix in
which one dimension would be yes or to
empathic affiliation but the dimension
would be the interpolation agonize
extrapolation and basically using this
particular matrix you can construct
examples and evaluate utilization for
each particular box so what you are
going to do if your impact of
affiliation you're going to keep n minus
back one party affiliation constant and
you're going to vary the inner factor
variation along its axis basically doing
the pollution as it is extrapolation
you're going to construct the
f-distribution similarly if you have n
samples or in fact of a variation and
you take some particular content sample
for interpolation and extrapolation it's
going to give you a matrix containing n
cross P numbers and that matrix it's
actually going to tell you how well or
how bad the agent is actually performing
so that is anything new as compared to
evaluating a single scalar I think it
does so it's possible that some
particular agents can actually do build
will across one party affiliation that
is you can Freeman agents still
navigated n number of rooms but as long
as it had a small object it may possible
that agent doesn't know how to do it
stuff so that disturbance is not really
forward you know killer quantity so this
kinda imputed thing since we already
noting that these are the factor of
variation and these are the factors
which we care about the wish could also
hope for learning that the biases which
could help the ancients to become
equivalent or invariance along a
particular axis
so from this means the definition of an
acid ice becomes really in theaters in
general everything is relevant at the
bias that you can actually find many
single inductive biases smoothness
relation shorter accomplished mobility
every single thing
actually an inductive bath but whatever
is metal battles which are really useful
now the proposal is the inductive bias
which helps our chain to become
invariant or equivalent along a
particular path constellations are the
ones which are really useful and
wonderful trollese mean let's say again
you have impactful affiliation you're
the repel in that the bias which lets
you invariant all curate for one setting
of factors now you have additional set
of ocean environments your inductive
bias incorporate that inductive bias so
what's that little to do is it lets you
marsh lice or the factor variation which
your agent has invading the work or the
cue in the work and it gives you a new
set of environments in which you
actually learn the controls the third
space in a very effective way using the
prior knowledge which agent has already
developed in the form of inductive bias
now the question again is how to learn
main doctor bias so I'm not going to
sell anything about learning the
inductive bias yet I'm saying what are
the useful inductive biases and one easy
answer is just by biases which has to
generalize or particular factor of
variation and it out
yeah
so that's the second original edition
you can talk about right now is just
assuming that imagine you're training
each of these access individually I'll
get you a point later in the slides
I'm going to talk about that lately so
what it basically amounts now it amounts
to finding reducing this whole set
problem into three step drop well I'm
fine the fact is a variation basically
the same work done by Rishabh NGO so
controllable factors and stuff building
next devices that achieve experience
along with particular access and the
last layer violating a machine learning
methods along the specific access
remember right line machine learning are
specifically reinforced in learning
multi-touch turning continue learning
the only way to value it is to measure a
scalar quantity on a fixed set of
distribution a fixed set of tasks
there's even the notion of phase
distribution like there are many many
papers who don't really report the
notion of phase distribution and these
sort of problems it is surprising okay
the difference between like some people
sometimes ask me like what's the
difference between transfer learning
better learning and multitask learning
so this was quantified that imagine
you're trained you have a training
distribution between comprised of
environment a environment be environment
C or some set of environments you
Freeman owner if you're treating a
learner to evaluate on the environment
from the same distribution it means
you're sort of doing multi-touch
learning but if you're producing
hypotheses or if you're learning and
method bias which helps you to analyze
not over the same set of distribution
but potentially in punishing future
tasks you're actually developing
inductive biases which helps each in
place not only for that task but
potentially many many jobs now it's true
that since you don't really know what
the future taps are going to be you
don't really know which inductive bias
is going to be useful or not so that's
why the importance of seeing many
training examples during your testing so
that you can find features or you can
learn the structure which is equally
four invariants any questions
just to recap I begin the doctor saying
the three words inductive biases
invariance and generalization and I want
legitimization and the use of the
starboard parametric is just because the
agent isn't an example it knows what's
the granted it it doesn't know what the
drunkard data generating description is
but the hope is by interacting with the
environment they didn't can finally
start variation and once I did move
those factors affiliation you can
evaluate utilization along the factor of
variation since here the generalization
is part of a function of your training
distribution in the sense like what are
the factors of variation which is sort
of feared because that sort of opposite
to the traditional sensor generalization
now the word invested by C's just
because you have these optional factors
of variation you've helped the urchins
become anyway articulated for that
particular access now mostly when we
talk about how we can learn in dr.
Pisces which can help you actually
generalize for a particular axis or
along a particular axis so there's a
very famous truth task which actually
motivated me behind doing this
particular problem so this truth path
actually says that there to set up
there's the same problem but they're the
same words but there are two problems
one in which you have to actually just
read the words and second you have to
actually feed back up the words in which
it is written
if you middle of words is actually very
easy but reading the color of the words
actually takes amount of cognitive
effort does it section for everyone like
reading also screen it's super easy but
getting this for the combination is not
really same it doesn't fix the amount of
times as the second one so I'm color
blind so it doesn't matter for me but
there's a reason behind the users like
as humans we are very accustomed to a
people response or we have
reading like we read all the time so
reading doesn't take any cognitive
effort reading a sort of effortless but
whenever we are actually doing something
which takes some effort it actually
takes more time so that's why it takes
more time to read the colors as compared
to reading the word and this combination
or this notion that they sort of a
default behavior status of leading and
there's a behavior that you should
degress from when you get some external
reward that inclusion I'm going to use
to motivate that this was just insane
right reinforcement learning problem you
have a particular a change agent is
taking action in the real world and it
gets new state it gets reward so the
object of an important learning problem
is to maximize this expected reward for
return so in order just again I'm mostly
going to formulate or change my data
input into two parts one is privileged
input and what is under import and I'm
going to argue that by converting this
or by making this assumption distilling
can pass a huge amount of or a huge set
of problems so this does not lose any
generality so there are many problems
which this will ask what's the problem
say it's a goal condition policies the
green condition policy is like between a
policy which is conditioned on not on
your states but the goal also which the
agent is trying to achieve this goal can
be given the language instruction or
anything else
similarly the set of wrinkled highlights
whose enforcement learning problems
where you have a set of dual policies
and your set of managers so the manager
tells the little policies what to do how
to do the command from this high level
controller or command on this file with
a controller actually a as a privileged
input and the Nuala will take or the
each state of the primitive actually
send an input for each parameters
similarly in mortgage planning involves
free RS when assuming as an agent having
access to a more beeps planner so I can
run the a chain I can run the planner I
can get the output of the planner and
you start as a privileged inputs what
because in order to do this in order to
take this particular input you require
some extra effort or require some more
computation you probably want to either
minimize the set of computations or you
actually want to generalize with that
particular set of distribution of inputs
so it means I feel like any single
problem you can actually break the input
into two parts standard and published
wing back to the relation is fast which
I showed you
let's say you're training a good
condition policy it takes the state of
the a chain which respond EP here and it
also takes the group who can be
described in language form or anything
else then green condition policies what
a girl is is to learn a policy which
take the state as less course and the
doubt overfitting to any one particular
because it's a standard needle network
and if there's not a well-defined
training set or it's not a large enough
training set what could possibly happen
it could actually all fit this
particular policy or this protein
learning algorithm and actually offer it
to one particular individual so we don't
really want that behavior again the
objective is same we need to generate
the new goals as well as you want to
offer it to any single code so how can
we print the set of problems where you
have a standard impurity of a privileged
inputs you want to make best use of the
privileged input basically you want to
generalize respect to privileged input
as well as you kind of want to prevent
overfitting so one little thing to
define is is actually minimize the
mutual information of that action with
respect to the privileged input here
when your standard input so what it says
is like imagine if I'm a change and my
peer here my action should be
independent of privileged input as many
times as possible but when using the
finish input let me get higher reward or
let me solve something quickly then I
should actually use that particular
information
intuitively imagine that in a chain and
it needs to solve a task that as it
needs to go to a practical goal it has a
gue either to eat that eat burger so
till fear no matter wait decides to go
like in the burger or pizza it has to
walk straight to the mission would be
zero up is a point tilde for the next
day and one storage in the action
reaches here it needs to actually take a
decision that should actually go to eat
burger Pepita so if the goal is burger
it has to decide how to go sort of pinch
play not fast and if I need to go to eat
pizza I need to go north east so at that
particular point the mutual information
between your actions and the goals given
the standard input could be high but
once you have committed to a particular
goal the agent actually doesn't really
need to remember anything else that you
use it's only standard input that is it
can minimize the mutual information
between two actions and goals because it
doesn't really need to use bows anymore
does that make sense so one of the ways
narrative achieve this kind of
generalization in machine learning is
using the framework that a
transformation what like what a machine
working does is do you have a Markov
chain like the of input representation
it learns a watling's representation see
about the import which can be used to
learn some particular to learn about the
operatic output distribution why so the
goal is to minimize the mutual
information between the input as lies
the bottlenecks condition and maximize
the mutual information between thirties
and willis outputs so basically any me I
tell shows the variation of pay to
actually compute this in a particular
tractable form which they assume to
penalize the clear between your encoder
absolute supplier and called the supers
problem that is a prediction problem as
you were doing before it's just
basically about charting this particular
kills them
so what it intuitively does is it says
you have sort of input features it
includes the input very compressible
compresses that is an inputs which you
don't really need for better
generalization and the features is the
weight decides which we just to avoid is
by using the features which are actually
used for output so it puts all the
pressure upon using what should be our
output should be so this information
dropout has actually been useful or
actually has been shown useful
personalization in many the machine
learning problems I'm going to metal
that similar inclusion to actually get
better generalization for my
reinforcement learning problems so for
me X would be like privileged inferred
deep would again be a my standard like
divyam what link absenting why would the
actual distribution and for me since I
have also a fixed standard input it
would be conditional variant of the
information what length so remember just
remember that I family that if want to
clean a policy which can not only solve
one particular goal but can solve a wide
variety of course without overfitting to
any single individual codes and I
founded that they could be done this
particular way by making use of theta
processing quality which they start in a
magical you could have the mutual
information in your output given the
input should be less than equal to
mutual information between your what
length representation and the input so
this sort of architecture lets you
develop yellow state which is your
standard inferred yanukovich input you
learn the fortunate representation P
this becomes your encoder take a
standard encoder in machine learning
problems then you have a decoder which
makes use what are the standard input as
well as of the what link representation
in order to get your desired behavior a
the important thing to notice the
information flow between promise States
to action and follow two particular path
one is dark information flow from your
state deductions other is the first you
include the representation area encode
the information between your style
import as well as input into a water
like representation C and then a
consequence the information about three
make sense any questions out Thank You
ten or clear angles I have a question a
simple example imagine that in aging
again it has to decide whether to eat
pizza or burger and those your goals so
something from the goals the property of
goods here is high at the burger and
pizza pie so right in the middle region
needs to commit to a particular goal and
when it has commit to a particular goal
then it can just follow to fall failure
status since part X my encoding and when
it has onboard including is at this
particular issues region touch the side
vertical type would end up taking
Samantha's words or semantic information
about the goals and storing that
information into the written
representation T otherwise with that
particular point step the killer between
the including and prior bhai just
because the leading food contains
information about your goal but at all
of the states begins extremely little
code to actually close to the prior so
it tells you two things one as I said
before the two layers of transporting
information
one is the marginals of the latent
variable T or possible goals and second
is you use a good information
the fourth conducts is the learner
default policy or default behavior in
whatever stage is possible and second
kind of information scissors
when it was drifting from your default
behavior actually gives you high reward
you should actually use your privilege
input so there's an interesting
inspiration with from cognitive science
and AG literature cognitive science is
that there two modes of vision making
one is like automatic responses whenever
you are doing something sometimes we
don't really require any thinking and
one is like perpetual thinking a control
action selection that is whenever you
have to do something you actually need
to think properly in order to decide
what to do a more concrete example of
the task remember in this particular
task eating was easy reading the words
was very easy but reading the color of
the words was difficult and that's
because but the false reading is a
default behavior because you read all
the time so that's why it becomes easy
but in order to do some sort of
liberation
you require to really think about what
the color of the world is or the water
calendar which the world it's written so
okay just to summarize what I said I've
been a change who has a standard input
and was a pill version for now they
didn't want to generalize the defect of
this privileged input and in order to
start I proposed information regulator
which activity specialization that's my
book can it actually does that and now
in order to evaluate invitation I'm
going to vary one particular factor of
variation which is the number of rooms
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
train in four grooms the you say the
particular for where they didn't gets a
new title for that is four pixels their
four pixels and I'm going to trainers
attempted on particular distribution
similarly here
I'm going to clean up a distribution and
I'm going to test on something which it
has never seen during this thing during
training so I avoid this we know find
object a spice basically in tune with
the room 35 and I trained on objects
which have you cited seven absolutely
resided then basically the simple seven
to ten and I'm training on only pilot
uses like the size of the rooms is five
so this is just a cool condition
baseline where I am still just doing the
winning that state-of-the-art
performance from normal reinforcement
learning methods and then this is my
method where we showed that in carbon in
this sort of here here actually actually
generalizes better so now you can argue
that since I'm training on political
environment and testing on them or the
particular environment the agent can
have issues because in one particular
column or in one particular baseline I
had no particular baseline which
actually learnt the structure of the
environment so we compared to another
exploration methods exceed up the our
exploration methods and of the two basic
methods are like armies exploration film
L and curiosity exploration you go to
places which are curious about so you
make a prediction and you see if they
are good or not and if the prediction
about the Explorer in those regions
again the important difference here is
all these expression baselines
they are tasked aspects in order to
explore they don't really it's like the
structure of the problem but the sort of
a polish utilization using information
bottleneck which actually does utilize
the structure of the task at hand what I
give meant by that
remember I felt like our policy has an
input I have a progression board I want
my poly
to actually come into a default behavior
at most of the state that is not users
will at all but at certain states we are
using goal actually changes default
behavior that needs to are award it
should actually do that so this
particular diversion from its default
behavior a using particular particular
information it's actually the structure
turned line structure of the task at
hand in order to just said that I took
these particular measures so the goal of
the images is you have to start from
this particular open dot and you have to
reach to the goal and along the way I've
plotted kill kill of the encoder tale of
basically this particular thing along
the trajectory so as you can see near
all the potential sub goals or near the
junctions the agents end up requiring
equal information which is sort of
obvious or which is sort of clear
because in the junctions because of the
branch factor
agent doesn't really know where to go
but while you're walking in the collie
dose the only action is you can either
keep walking straight or you can you're
already have committed to a behavior you
can't just change back you need to
either go straight or go back so the
states where the division from your
default which happens I call this
decision states fix cars with
interchanging from its default behavior
which will start agnostic do something
which requires thinking really about it
school that is what it needs to do in
order to achieve its goal so they did
this actively taking our decision
about the Stroop effect in which the
goal is to actually read the colors and
show it like how reading is more easy as
compared to actually reading the colors
of the or the fellows the words in which
they are written so the same idea could
also be applied for all these problems
we are the paper about the iclear will
be valid on all these different problems
and for mood fills in actually refer to
the expert the paper itself and open
with reaction from our lab Daniel Straus
and Matthew Boulton come define it will
come to the brain circuit from Berkeley
and one Chris Miller okay I'm going to
quickly just summarize again what I said
so in most of the cases the goal is to
learn and encode coder this is the
normal generator models very unlearning
an encoder and this is what I suppose in
which you learn encoder over the states
or the provision portal is the standard
import the one thing which is a big
field about my method or about the
proposed method they start even though
excessive output at each time step
you're you're compressing it you're
basically accessing the input and then
compressing it that kill cost in the
same task that don't use the good
information at all the time serfs use
that only those time steps when it is
needed
but remember the include is still
encoding that particular information
even they start using it within 13 many
problems can be in a very non efficient
that if you don't really want to encode
you don't really want to first and
closing Commission and then compress
because this type of information on the
first base can be very difficult to
actually obtain on the very first base
for example this particular information
the G will involve running and what is a
stanner which could be extensor this
could involve or the fact employment
problems in which you have to kind of
ask a particular human in the loop it's
good again dec Spencer
so I feel like touch one of the biggest
problems right now in thinking about
these sort of encoders in generative
modeling how can we build methods which
in order to convince them they don't
really just acquire them for like it
should be operative like depending on
something you decide when to exercise
silver chain ports and if you have
decided that I'm going to exert it then
only I use it so intuitively if there
exists a method ABC the right way to do
things would be if I'm an agent I'm
navigating the particular mesh force I
decide okay I'm at a junction point and
I don't really know what to do so I'm
going to ask for help and then I'm going
to the patient my current state I'm
going to conditionally access the
privileged inputs and then this with
respect to that particular inputs are
going to compress it not including the
input at all time steps and then only
compressing it does that make sense like
majority in every single work which has
been done in literature in general
modeling what you're supposed to do is
you encode the input first and then you
compress it but what about the input you
know section input can be expensive to
obtain or what about the scenarios in
which this particular encoder can itself
illusion lies then you're kind of losing
things in two ways one the encoders are
generalizing which is bad taking you're
even using some kind of an external
expensive computation and you are just
throwing it away can we do something
better indeed only what one can do is
this is just on an input this is your
intuitive way of addressing this
particular problem would be based upon
your son inputs you decide whether to
actually fetch or whether to actually
get the privilege input or not and only
get it if you actually require it so
sort of quick sort of dually conditional
computations in order to accessor
running out of time I'm just going to
motivate this problem but this is a big
problem that we should be thinking of
condition computations that is how can
we change from this notion of static
forward process like we have a big
neural network in which everything is
deterministic in which we know what to
do things needed to compute the higher
are the functions and we actually use
that but maybe that's not the right way
maybe one way to think is how can we
modify the job in half I think this is a
really interesting research problem it
should be studied by both people this
was again work done by what done and
this first version was massive what
income defines the guillotine and yasha
venture in sort of my to now use so we
are motivated the problem was if I'm any
change I should have a sort of a
deliberation power in order to decide
whether they should I sort of require
this particular input or external input
or not but can we make a sort of a
unified way in order to see when we need
to access it or should be accepted or
not so I started with the saying that if
your learner you do learn some biases
and you do need some biases in origin
lights press but then I talked about
okay how we can learn pisces if you are
given I've written opening distribution
and then once we describe the outside
then I said like what's next
so imagine they asked researchers if we
have to research a tackle a research
problem we just don't really are driven
by the observation if you have a
research problem we know what's the
problem at hand so let's say I have a
paper which I'm going to submitted in
Terps and I know what my hypothesis
about the papers are then I do
experiments in order to confirm those
hypotheses are I do experiment in order
to cut off oppose what by underlying
hypothesis are so intuitively we just
don't really explode we find
like human beings or as researchers we
actually make hypotheses about our
underlying problems and then we do
experiments in order to be the confirmed
of hypotheses or denied all hypotheses I
feel like that's a very that's a very
sort of interesting way to actually
think important because now all the
deliberations actually goes into how you
actually some of the hypotheses in the
first place I don't really know the
answer to how this is actually happening
but I feel like the underlying problem
at hand actually tells you a lot about
what their hypotheses are going to be in
the sense like the a human being feels
really really really really good at
coming of the new problems I don't
really know why I start the case but
long with those even solve our problems
we have a very intuitive form we have a
very intuitive notion of how hard the
problem could be like I know if I'm
going to prove something I want you to
in understanding whether I can do it or
not or I also know what might a
potential answer would look like so
these are the hints about the problems
which actually tries the hypothesis
driven formulation and it's interesting
to note that aside from the machine
learning community as compared to
cognitive science or psychology they
actually do experiments in sort of a
hybrid driven be the first form later
particular hypotheses then you do extra
dimensional to qualify them on sort of
invalidate them unlike machine learning
where you really have to do experiments
in order to show that you are doing best
in the entire table I don't really know
why do we have or why do we are so good
at coming of new problems Thanks maybe
one reason is I don't think so the we
are the reason we come up with new
problems just because we are smart
I feel like exactly the opposite this is
like coming up with new problems makes
us a fuchsbau or makes us to be smart
other thing is if you already have a
problem at hand you are - - straining
your search space you know what you're
supposed to look for so I feel this is
whatever is the kind of start in a PhD
school so if I
bottom space and taste hey you know
little problem space find the right
hypothesis and find how can we had cost
this particular problem in the first
place and it's not even the problem
which matter if it's actually the
approach which take to kind of solve
that problem which matter because the
solution to that problem is something
which in generalize for a balance in REO
which are nothing get it could see in
the future
again this was work done with amazing
collaborators and yeah
[Applause]
here right now I assume that the data
and goals are will independent random
variables any other thank you for
listening
[Applause]